I'm going to open my heart to you today
and share some convictions that I have
about the church specifically about the
church that I love the Seventh Day
Adventist
Church questions are being raised today
will the church survive will it be
broken up into
independent organizational structures
and will it be divided and fragmented
serious questions are being raised about
whether the church is going to survive
some people are asking is it necessary
for faithful Believers to leave the
church is he leading people to be part
of some movement that is separate from
the organized body to be faithful to
scripture I'm going to present the
evidence from both the Bible and the
writings of Ellen White now I recognize
very well that if a person has already
made up their mind if they're a severe
critic of the church not much that I can
say is going to influence them so
critics and Skeptics are not my target
audience my target audience today are
honeste hearted people that are asking
serious questions that want biblical
answers well hey there so glad that you
could join us especially if this is your
first time with us Adventist or
otherwise you know a lot of times I'll
hear from Adventists that I am allegedly
evidence that Ellen White was a
legitimate Prophet because she claimed
that naysayers would come along partly
those of us that once believed her to be
legitimate and that we would then come
up against her the sort of
self-fulfilling prophecy was a favorite
move of most false prophetic leaders
throughout history but utilizing that
same faulty standard I predicted that
before beginning answering adventism
that the division and confusion within
the movement would only worsen and the
self-fulfilling prophecy has been
Vindicated once again the writing has
been on the wall for quite some time
which is precisely the problem time the
end of the world should have come by now
such that one shouldn't even be here to
even read the writing on the wall
anymore but here we are nevertheless new
drama has sparked within the Adventist
Universe prompted by the cancellation of
an SDA Pastor by the name of Conrad Vine
particularly with some statements that
he has made regarding the SDA Church's
handling of the covid-19 pandemic this
little Kur fuffle has led to a variety
of prominent SDA voices taking their
sides in what appears to be a
cancellation campaign however what has
come from all of that buzz is uh the
topic and discussion of an SDA Church
split it's important to understand the
LoveHate relationship between three key
Adventist doctrines when discussing this
subject namely the shaking The Remnant
in Babylon I like to think of this
Trifecta as an inescapable cycle of
finger pointing and self-fulfilling
prophecy something we will be talking
about throughout the night generally
speaking the shaking is their teaching
around there being a falling away period
before the return of Jesus where the
posers within the movement will fall
away the doctrine on the remnant entails
the fundamental concept that they are
united in ways that protestantism is not
such that they are a distinct and
separate people called out from all of
that confusion and their belief on
Babylon is intimately connected with
this Babylon supposedly representing
protestantism which the SDA Church sees
as their focus to call people out of to
come join them as the remnant otherwise
the wrath of God is stored up for them
and they won't be prepared for the
second coming this Trifecta produces a
never-ending cycle of division fueled by
fear that keeps many Adventists locked
into the system despite how obviously
false it is based on the organization's
own standards but despite this glaring
fact the SDA Church's concept of the
shaking then swoops in with its Cape to
keep an Adventist Who Dares question
leaving from doing so lest they fall
away from God's last day Remnant people
thus the cycle never ends but why is
this Trifecta an inescapable cycle of
finger points and self-fulfilling
prophecy because adventism is steeped in
division and every time something
divisive gets the spotlight the focus
becomes shifted to who is the remnant
some Adventists going so far as to claim
that there is a Remnant within the
remnant which only further heightens the
division leading to both sides pointing
at each other as the subjects of the
shaking and then simultaneously using
that as proof that the shaking is
happening but at the same time adventism
is supposed to be immune from doctrinal
division and finger pointing part of
their core identity and evidence that
they are the chosen end times people of
God as the Adventist inspired Penn tells
us in her conflict of the AG of series
quote the term Babylon derived from
Babel and signifying confusion is
applied in scripture to the various
forms of false or apostate religion but
the message announcing the fall of
Babylon must apply to some religious
body that was once pure and has become
corrupt it cannot be the romish church
which is here meant for that church has
been in a fallen condition for many
centuries but how appropriate the figure
as applied to the Protestant churches
all professing to derive their doctrines
from the Bible yet divided into almost
innumerable sects the unity for which
Christ prayed does not exist instead of
one Lord One Faith one baptism there are
numberless conflicting Creeds and
theories religious Faith appears so
confused and discordant that the world
know not what to believe as truth God is
not in all this it is the work of man
the work of Satan now now despite the
somewhat comedic irony of this quote it
allows one to see that there isn't
supposed to be doctrinal disagreements
and division within adventism that's
supposed to be relegated to all those
Babylonian Protestants and there
definitely isn't supposed to be
splitting or splintering that's supposed
to be foreign to the movement's unique
identity as the remnant and while the
division around Conrad Vine isn't
directly doctrinal it has bubbled the
doctrinal trifecta that I mentioned back
up to the surface which is why I want us
to listen to SDA Pastor Mark Finley
discuss some of these divisions and more
closely analyze the SDA Church's
identifying claims about itself as well
as test the SDA Church by their own
standard of Babylon in light of the
current infighting as Mark made clear in
that intro clip his message is not for
critical thinkers but for those that
want their security in the organization
to be reinforced and coddled either way
it provides us with a perfect
opportunity to test some of these
theological claims at the heart of all
of this to show what the way of escape
from the trifect of deception
is now here's a fundamental question is
there apostasy in the church or is the
church in apostasy there's a big
difference between those two things
obviously there's apostasy in the church
the wheat and tears are going to grow
together till the
Harvest but if you say the church is in
apostasy then you are akin to saying
that the church is Babylon and you
invite people to leave it all right so
that's exactly correct if the SDA church
is in apostasy then they would be a part
of Babylon according to their prophet's
alleged inspired definition of what
Babylon is without getting into the
nitty-gritty about how the SDA church is
absolutely an apostate organization that
preaches a false gospel a false god all
filtered through the worldview given to
them by a false prophet very clearly by
Church mark means the SDA organization
the wheat and the tears are supposed to
be representative of their movement
since the rest of us are Babylon and
outside of the fold but like I said
earlier despite the SDA church so
obviously fitting the bill for their own
definition of Babylon Mark recognized
that if this is true then you open the
door to invite people to leave adventism
this is also exactly correct because
this is supposed to be one of the
selling points for being a 7th Day
Adventist quote of Babylon at this time
it is declared her sins have reached to
heaven and God hath remembered her
iniquities Revelation 18:5 she has
filled up the measure of her guilt and
destruction is about to fall upon her
but God still has a people in Babylon
and before the visitation of his
judgments these faithful ones must be
called out that they partake not of her
sins and receive not of her plagues
hence the movement symbolized by the
angel coming down from heaven lightening
the Earth with his glory and crying
mightily with a strong voice announcing
the sins of Babylon in connection with
his message the call is heard come out
of her my people as These Warnings join
the third Angel's message it swells to a
loud cry close quote this is to say
Protestants are allegedly partaking in
the sins of the wicked world and the SDA
movement feels it is their duty to call
people out of that and join them before
it's too late which is precisely what's
found on the SDA Church's website as
their mission to proclaim the Three
Angels messages of which the call to
come out of Babylon is a part so if part
of their organizational Mission and
unique identity is to call people out of
what's supposed to be Babylon then it
means that they can't in any way fit the
bill for such or that mission becomes
null and void which is ultimately what
Mark Finley is getting at and why this
critical area deserves a particular
significant focus when analyzing the
validity of this
movement now there are four great truths
that we're going to take a look at first
an understanding of how God will purify
his church at end time secondly an
understanding of God's view of church
organization thirdly an understanding of
the difference between apostasy in the
church and the church being in apostasy
and fourthly an understanding of God's
plan for finishing his work so let's
Dive Right into our topic God's method
of purifying his church if you look
throughout history God has always called
out faithful Believers God called out
Abraham from the Nations around him so
that Abraham's family would not be
infected with the heresy of
idolatry God called out the Jewish
Nation to be his own special people
according to Deuteronomy from Egyptian
bondage after God called them out he
worked within the Jewish Community
giving them the 10 commandments to lead
them again from false gods and idolatry
and lead them back back to Sabbath
observance and he gave them specific
laws that would govern and guide the
Jewish Community God called them
out as the Jewish Nation drifted from
God's original purpose God called out
the New Testament Christian Church in
fact the word church is Ecclesia in the
Greek language EC meaning uh uh out and
accacia meaning called so God called out
the New Testament Christian Church as
the church grew large it entered into
apostasy God has always had faithful men
and women in every phase of church
history down through the centuries but
as the Christian Church grew large
church and state United you know the
story well shortly after the days of
Constantine by the time you come to 538
ad uh we have the mideval church the
Roman Catholic Church a church that
during the Middle Ages persecuted the
people of God a church that was in
apostasy so what did God do he called
out of the medieval Church the
Protestant Reformation the Protestant
reformers were the called out ones you
have the wenes you have hus and Jerome
obedience to God was their motto
faithfulness to scripture Martin Luther
Martin Luther with salvation is by grace
through faith and you have the Baptist
and the anabaptist movements baptism by
immersion and the methodists that talk
about Holiness and the millerite
movement that talks about the Advent of
Christ and Sabbath Keepers God called
out of the larger body of protestantism
the Seventh Day Adventist Church to
restore the truths of scripture that had
been lost sight of down through the ages
in the medieval church at the union of
church and state but some of which were
recovered by the reformers so the
Seventh Adventist Church is a called out
body so the fundamental thesis of the
discussion around adventism being the
remnant is predicated upon error and
historical revisionism which is exactly
what the great controversy worldview
does it distorts and rewrites to try and
support a pretextual narrative none of
the Protestant reformers none of them
had this view of history that Mark is
trying to associate them with none of
them believe that the church went into
apostasy during the Middle Ages and that
God raised them up to essentially
restore the church which is important in
this discussion because the trifecta of
claims is built upon this fundamental
error as church historian Philip schaf
notes in his book principles of
protestantism quote to be true to its
own idea a Reformation must hold its
course Midway or through the Deep rather
between two Extremes in opposition on
the one side to Revolution or a radical
and violent over overthrow of an
existing system it must attach itself
organically to what is already at hand
and grow forth thus from the trunk of
history in regular living Union with its
previous development in opposition to
simple restoration on the other side or
a mere repetition of the old it must
produce from the womb of this the birth
of something new and then he continues a
couple Pages later where he writes in
the first place we contemplate the
Reformation in its strictly historical
condition its Catholic Union with the
past this is a vastly important point
which thousands in our day appear to
overlook entirely they see in the 31st
of October 1517 when Martin Luther
nailed the 95 thesis it is true the
birthday of the Evangelical Church and
find her certificate of baptism in the
95 thesis of Luther but at the same time
cast a deep stain upon the legitimacy of
this birth Itself by separating it from
all right relation to the time that went
before in this way all interest is
renounced in the spiritual wealth of the
Middle Ages which however belongs to us
of right as fully at least it does to
the Church of Rome and what is worse
still the LIE is given practically to
the Lord's promise itself lo I Am With
You Always even to the end of the world
so the Protestant reformers saw
themselves as entirely attached to the
medieval Church whether you agree with
them or disagree with them is neither
here nor there the point being they did
not believe that the church was
completely apostate and that starting
with Martin Luther it needed to be
restored the Church can be thought of as
a tree Jesus planted this tree and over
time some of the branches became
diseased the diseased branches picturing
doctrinal accretions that aren't
ultimately rooted in scripture these
branches then needed to be pruned back
but this is vastly different than
thinking that the core trunk or root of
the tree was diseased such that a new
one needed to be planted or raised up
and as scha importantly points out the
Protestant reformers saw themselves as
invested interested and rightful
recipient of the spiritual wealth of the
Middle Ages not that the Church of the
Middle Ages was apostate what shof put
forth is not compatible with adventism
fundamental framework and it's one of
the key pieces of evidence that the SDA
movement is not Protestant they have
simply tried to cherry-pick certain
things from those individuals by
claiming they all had something to
contribute to the whole but the systems
that they themselves affirmed were still
apostate adventism is supposed to be the
entire collection of all of the correct
restored truths from each varying group
all housed in one place as the 100%
doctrinally pure Remnant completely
distinct and separate from Babylon as
SDA historian George Knight documents in
his book search for identity quote North
American protestantism of the 19th
century was a child of the 16th century
Reformation many Adventists are aware of
that fact but have mistakenly concluded
that their church is an heir of those
branches of the Reformation initiated by
Martin Luther John Calvin or R zwingley
while it is true that Adventist concept
of salvation by grace through faith
comes through the mainline reformers the
theological orientation of adventism
really finds itself more at home with
what church historians call the radical
Reformation or the
anabaptist this is a more accurate
summation of adventism connection to
protestantism which is why what Mark
Finley presented is not accurate and it
puts a crack in the foundational claims
that he is parting from the great
controversy the SDA movement is more
akin to the anabaptist radical reformers
what Philip schaf referred to as
radicalists not Protestant the
Protestant reformers would have
denounced William Miller and LG white as
what they were false prophets and
schismatics yet what Mark is saying here
about history is necessary for their
entire concept of the remnant in Babylon
to be true and it's built upon
historical revisionism and error
remember this as he begins to try and
present a Biblical case for this now the
devil hates the Advent movement
Revelation 12:1
17 make no
mistake the devil will do everything he
can to destroy the Advent movement
Revelation 12 verse 17 the dragon Satan
was enraged with the woman the church he
goes to make war with the rest of her
Offspring which keep the Commandments of
God and have the testimony of Jesus
Christ so the devil is making war with
God's church so the question is will God
keep calling out like he did in the days
of Abraham like he did in the days of
Israel like he did in the New Testament
like he did with the Reformation like he
did with the early Advent movement is
God going to keep calling out a
movement not according to the SDA
Church's Prophet as he's not who claimed
to be shown in Vision that God had
rejected the wicked world and the time
of their salvation was passed quote I
saw that Jesus prayed for his enemies
but that should not cause us to pray for
the Wicked World whom God has rejected
when he prayed for his enemies there was
hope for them and they could be
benefited and saved by his prayers and
also after he was a mediator in the
outer apartment for the whole world but
now his spirit and sympathy were
withdrawn from the world and our
sympathy must be with Jesus and must be
withdrawn from the ungodly close
quote which is perfectly consistent with
her first Vision in December of 1844
branded as the path Vision or should I
say alleged vision where she also
claimed that God had rejected the Wicked
World the time of their salvation was
passed probation was closed and no more
Sinners could be saved and those
millerites that gave up on the movement
fell off the path down into the wicked
world that God had rejected this same
thing was being stated all the way up in
1851 and was allegedly confirmed both
times in vision and for Adventists that
want to rely on the defense that the
Camden New York Vision was a forgery
that wasn't actually written by Ellen
White take that up with pastors and
olist within your own ranks such as
Kevin Morgan who was on this platform
and utilized that Vision to try and
prove that Ellen White is a legitimate
Prophet Mark asked if God is still
calling people out to come join them as
the remnant not according to his
prophetess who claim to be shown by God
that Jesus no longer sympathizes with
the lost and doesn't pray for them
because they can no longer be benefited
and saved by his prayers and she
implored the early Adventist to follow
suit because God's sympathy and spirit
had supposedly withdrawn from the world
and to disagree with this is to call
into question the Adventist claim to
being the remnant if Ellen White was
wrong then she's a false prophet and by
their own definition they aren't the
remnant with the spirit of Prophecy if
she was correct and they want to defend
that then the answer to Mark's question
is no God isn't calling people into
their movement including Mark Finley or
any Adventist today because God
supposedly stopped sympathizing with and
calling people out of the world in the
19th century quite the catch 22 God is
calling people out of the World by way
of his church his body of Believers all
over the world who Herald the gospel
given to the apostles by Jesus Christ
himself this gospel transforms people
and when they believe it by faith they
are transferred from the kingdom of
darkness into the Kingdom of Light they
are made citizens of Christ's Kingdom
and living stones in the body of Christ
of which Christ is the head the Chief
Cornerstone but this has nothing to do
with adventism though Jesus Jesus Christ
has been doing this long before the SDA
movement existed and will continue doing
so long after the SDA movement is
scrapped to the scrap pile of History
God is not calling people out of the
world to join a sectarian movement that
has a novel gospel foreign to the
apostles in the Bible that's prizz a
different God than that of the Apostles
in the Bible what Mark actually means by
calling out is a whittling down
something we will talk about a little
bit later he asked if God is going to
keep calling people out like he did in
the days of Abraham like he did in the
New Testament and like he did in the
Reformation yet like I showed the
Reformation wasn't a separating act
separation only happened when the papal
office gave an ultimatum to either
submit or be excommunicated to which
Martin Luther exclaimed that his
conscience was bound to the word of God
thus sealing his fate but to acate this
with what Mark is talking about
regarding being called out is a totally
foreign concept to the reformers and any
of the other individuals in history that
he mentioned they weren't being called
out to join a sectarian movement which
wages war against the actual Body of
Christ but he also said that the devil
allegedly hates the Seventh Day
Adventist movement even though he was
the architect behind its schismatic
efforts and bearing a false witness
against the actual Body of Christ this
is the same Mark Finley you might recall
that told us that in his imagination he
saw Satan holding a diabolical council
meeting in outer space to conspire with
his demons against the Seventh Day
Adventist Church and the seventh day
Sabbath no seriously
in my
imagination in the outer darkness of
this world I picture a diabolical
scene some places in the far some place
in the far reaches of space a rebel
Angel meets with his demonic forces in a
strategy
session now the forces of evil and
darkness are eager to be successful in
their devilish
scheme in my imagination I see this
committee meeting if you please and the
devil is discussing with his evil angels
how best to undermine the authority of
Christ now to do this they determine in
that meeting to focus
particularly on the Sabbath they'll
attempt to discredit destroy and
demolish God's symbol of creation the
Sabbath in any way possible so they
begin to discuss this and they in my
imagination I hear them debating and
they decide on at least five major
objectives except as I showed in that
presentation by his imagination Mark
actually meant Ellen White's conflict of
the ages Series where she said this
exact same thing something scripture
obviously does not say anything about
simply reading Revelation 12:17 for the
10,000th time and asserting that it's
referring to the SDA church does not
prove it this is what the SDA Church
wants to be true and believes to be true
because they allegedly have a divinely
inspired interpreter of scripture that
tells them this but the SDA Church
prizes a false god on that ground alone
they can't fit the bill of their own
definition of the remnant and what's
actually fascinating about this fact in
the context of the remnant Babylon and a
future SDA Church split is that this is
one of the key areas of division within
the movement it's not only one of the
key reasons that evidence they are
Babylon based on their own definition
but it also evidences that they're not
the Commandment keeping Church of
Revelation 12:17 even if we did want to
grant them that their interpretation is
correct it's been a 170 plus years and
various Pockets exist within adventism
regarding pro- Heavenly Trio Advocates
and anti- Heavenly Trio Advocates the
Heavenly Trio for those unaware is the
unique God concept of the SDA Church
three different beings that are united
in a mission and a purpose which is
supposed to make them one single God as
SD historian and theologian Jerry Moon
writes in his book about the Heavenly
Trio quote more recently a further
question has arisen with increasing
urgency was the Pioneers belief about
the godhead right or wrong as one line
of reasoning goes either the Pioneers
were wrong and the present church is
right or the Pioneers were right and the
present 7th Day Adventist Church has
apostatized from Biblical truth and that
is exactly correct one pocket of
Adventists agree with the SDA Pioneers
while the modernists in the the movement
agree with the modern SDA Church which
disagrees in a number of ways from their
own pioneers and they can't have it both
ways yet they aren't supposed to have
doctrinal division like this as the
remnant called out of Babylon they're
supposed to be immune from such which
further demonstrates that they don't fit
the bill for their own interpretation of
Revelation 12:17 now we will look at
what the remnant in Revelation is in a
little bit but it's not looking very
good for the SDA Church based on their
own metrics and standards the situation
with Conrad Vine and the further
division that it is causing is really
only a symptom of the root problem which
is that the SDA movement was born out of
division and has only beget more of the
same thing as time goes on or begotten
you get my point there is no remnant of
a Remnant in the Bible Revelation 12:17
says and the dragon went to make war
with the woman and the remnant that is
those who remain faithful and LA to God
of her seed who keep the Commandments of
God and have the gift of Prophecy
there's not one shred of a text in the
Bible that talks about God calling out
of the remnant another Remnant in fact
if you look at the seven churches in
Revelation 2 and three you've got
Ephesus and Smyrna and pergamus and
thyra and Sardis and Philadelphia and
leoda what is what is the word Leia
means some people say a PE it means
lukewarm not at all that is the
condition of the leian church but the uh
word Leia means a people of judged the
people of the Judgment hour and remember
in Revelation chapter 3 when the Church
of leoda is introduced God says this is
the Amen in fact let's take a look at
that in Revelation chapter 3 when God
introduces
the seventh of these churches there is
no eighth there is no movement called
out of the lean Church in fact in
Revelation chapter 3 we look there at
chapter 3 and uh introducing the re
Revelation 3:14 to the angel of the
Church of leans write for these things
says the amen the faithful and true
witness the beginning of the creation of
God the things says the amen what does
amen mean means so be it amen you put it
at the end of the prayer so lead deia
according to God is the amen and where
is Jesus he is knocking on the door of
lead DEA so we want to be where God is
knocking so that we can open our hearts
to God so there is no remnant of a
Remnant there is no calling out of le le
is the Church of the Judgment
hour okay so he said there's only one
one Remnant and it's those that keep the
Ten Commandments and have the gift of
Prophecy which they alleged to possess
with Ellen White except as we saw
earlier Ellen claimed to be shown
multiple times in the 1800s that the
time of Salvation was up and the defense
that this took place before the SDA
Church's formal incorporation in 1863
does not provide her with prophetic
immunity which means that once again
utilizing their own definitions they
can't be the remnant because Ellen White
was a false prophet but Mark the fact
that you have people within your ranks
claiming to be the remnant within the
remnant further evidences that you guys
are not as United as you want us to
believe you're not immune from doctrinal
division and as a leader within the
higher echelons of the movement it's
very clear that this message is about
damage control not discovering the truth
a few weeks ago we looked at the
standard SDA claims regarding the leodan
church in Revelation and how they abuse
this to read themselves into the
narrative I won't rehash all of that
here but for those that are interested
the link to this is in the description
box down below so before one can even
navigate The Book of Revelation one must
land on their school of prophetic
interpretation to do such most
Adventists are simply fed the SDA
Church's novel form of historicism and
then they accept that as the plain
reading of the Bible typically alongside
the talking point that all of the
Protestant reformers were historicists
and Adventists are simply in line with
that and as I have pointed out numerous
times before no this is not true not all
of the reformers were historicist but
furthermore who cares even if they were
were that's not an argument that
historicism is indeed the correct one
the fact is all of the prophetic schools
of interpretation have their strengths
and weaknesses and when it comes to the
remnant the weaknesses of the SDA
framework make themselves most evidently
seen as Dr GK Beal notes in his
Revelation commentary before getting
into the book itself he explains what
the four primary schools of
interpretation are and the strengths and
weaknesses of each regarding historicism
he writes quote this view tries to
identify his historical movements too
specifically and limits the Prophecies
of the Apocalypse to western church
history leaving aside the worldwide
Church proponents of this view living at
different periods of church history
cannot agree with one another since they
limit the meaning of the symbols only to
specific historical reference
contemporary with their own times
another weakness of this approach is
that such a projection of future history
would have had very little relevance to
the first century readers of Revelation
and this is precisely what we see with
the SDA handling of ration it is read in
such a way that makes the book virtually
irrelevant to the vast majority of
Christian history let alone the original
audience that John was writing to to
make the remnant some small group of
people beginning in the 19th century is
to functionally make that part of
Revelation meaningless to the original
audience and it is for reasons such as
this that I personally would align more
with the modified idealist
interpretation which can both understand
the historical and present application
of the text without favoring one over
the other
as Beal also notes regarding modified
idealism quote a more viable modified
version of the idealist perspective
would acknowledge a final consummation
and salvation and judgment perhaps it
would be best to call this fifth view
eclecticism accordingly no specific
prophesied historical events are
discerned in the book except for the
final coming of Christ to deliver and
judge and to establish the final form of
the Kingdom in a consummated New
Creation though there are a few
exceptions to this rule the apocalypse
symbolically portrays events throughout
history which is understood to be under
the sovereignty of the lamb as a result
of his death and Resurrection he will
guide the events depicted until they
finally issue in the last judgment and
the definitive establishment of his
kingdom this means that specific events
throughout the age extending from
Christ's first coming to his second may
be identified with one narrative or
symbol the majority of the symbols in
the book are trans temporal in the sense
that they are applicable to events
throughout the church age therefore the
historicist May sometimes be right in
their precise historical identification
but wrong in limiting the identification
only as one historical reality the same
verdict may be passed on the predus
school of thought especially the Roman
version and certainly there are
Prophecies of the future in Revelation
The crucial yet problematic task of The
Interpreter is to identify through
careful ex aesus and against the
historical background those texts which
pertain respectively to past present and
future so from this Frame framework
notice what Dr Beal notes about the
remnant of Revelation 12:17 accordingly
Revelation 126 and 13-17 portrays the
devil as beginning his attack against
the church in the church's early stages
in order to destroy it quickly and
continuing the attack as long as the
church exists the pictoral distinction
between the woman and her seed could
represent the distinction between the
early Jewish church and the church's
subsequent Jewish and Gentile growth but
there is no intention to distinguish
between a Jewish Church church and a
later Gentile church since the church
continued to contain a remnant of Jews
nor is there a distinction between an
earlier Gentile church and a latter
Jewish remnant of 144,000 living During
a severe tribulation of the final few
years of History nor is there a
distinction between the whole nation and
a Remnant in the nation existing during
the same period the description of the
seed as those who keep the Commandments
of God and who hold to the testimony of
Jesus is open-ended and points to
including of Jews and Gentiles indeed
there is no clear indication elsewhere
in the apocalypse that John emphasized
any national distinctions in the church
the description here probably connotes
how all the Earthly Church throughout
the ages withstand the devil's attacks
according to Lad and beckwith's view
though very possibly the verse depicts
how the last historical stage of the
church's Offspring withstands Satan's
oppression the church gives the same
testimony as Jesus we have concluded
already in the comments on re Revelation
1:2 that the phrase testimony of Jesus
is intentionally ambiguous including
both the testimony from Jesus given to
the church and the testimony to Jesus
given by the church the focus of the
phrase may be on Jesus's testimony to
God which the church is to reproduce so
to properly understand Revelation one
has to understand the overall thesis and
framework of the book which was that
John the Apostle was writing to the
first century Church regarding the soon
persecution they were about to
and what we find is an overarching theme
of Christ's Victory and accomplishment
of redemption serving as a reminder to
them that Christ has overcome and will
overcome all of his enemies as he rules
and Reigns leading history to its
eventual consummation state with the
second coming and the union of Heaven
and Earth and this is the same
application that the book has for us
today it serves as encouragement and a
reminder that despite whatever may be
going on in the world Jesus has overcome
the world and his kingdom is advancing
with the the devil being a defeated foe
whose end is coming it is within this
framework that one must understand the
remnant of Revelation the ones that
Satan makes war with is all of those who
have been called out of the Beast system
the kingdom of darkness the lost world
and are made living stones in the
edifice that is the body of Christ
Christ has been building his church for
thousands of years and Satan has been
Waring against all of those individuals
that make up that kingdom of God from
the beginning to think that this took on
some brand new meaning in the 19th
centur Century beginning with the
Seventh Day Adventist and that Satan all
of a sudden started hating them and
everyone else all of a sudden just
became his subjects that he no longer
needed to war with is rather Juvenile
and it is a very self-centered reading
of the Bible in my opinion this is one
of the biggest weaknesses of the SDA
Church's interpretation of Revelation
and it clouds their handling of every
passage in the book The idealist or
modified idealist understanding of this
text allows one to make sense of how the
text has both immediate application to
the first Cent audience it was Penn to
as well as the modern reader 2,000 years
removed now Adventists are free to
disagree with that and they absolutely
will but at the end of the day they
don't have some special insight into
Revelation that no one else does they
have an interpretation just like
everyone else there are four chapters in
The Book of Revelation that have to do
with the true church Revelation chapter
10 is the historic rise of the true
church Revelation 12 is the identifying
characteristic of the true church keeps
the Commandments of God as the testimony
of Jesus Revelation 14 is the message of
the true church and Revelation three is
the spiritual condition of the true
church but wait if indeed there's not a
calling
out how will God purify his church at
end time it won't be a calling out of
the faithful it'll be a Shak out of the
Unfaithful and this is the key to
understanding why God is not going to
establish another movement an offshoot
movement a parachurch movement why not
because he's not going to call out the
faithful he's going to shake out the
Unfaithful now let's look at the
biblical evidence for this Hebrews chap
verse 25- 27 Hebrews 12 verse 25-
27 see that you do not refuse him who
speaks don't refuse him who speaks God
says for if they did not Escape who
refused him who spoke on Earth much more
shall we escape if we turn away from him
who speaks from Heaven whose voice then
shook the Earth but now he's promised
yet once more I shake not only the Earth
but also heaven now this yet once more
indicates don't miss this the removal of
those things that are being shaken as of
things that are made that the things
which cannot be shaken May remain verse
28 therefore since we are receiving a
kingdom which cannot be shaken let us
have Grace by which we may serve God
acceptably with reverence and godly fear
for our God is a consuming fire now
notice the things that cannot not be
shaken remain so what is it that can be
shaken those who are shaken are the
world conforming class they are indeed
the evildoers within the church they
indeed are the tears within the church
they're shaking now there's a difference
a little Nuance between the shaking and
the
sifting in the shaking let's let's just
suppose I have a big jar and in that jar
I walnuts and beans and I begin to shake
shake shake shake shake what's going to
happen well the heavier beans are going
to go where to the bottom the walnuts
are going to go to the top so the
shaking is a separation within we see
that taking place now let's suppose in
the bottom of that pan or jar I could
put holes big enough for the beans to go
through but too small for the walnuts
and I'm shaking What's Happening Now
there's a sifting and the beans going
through so the shaking is a separation
within the sifting is the
corresponding leaving of the church or
the going out from the church of those
who have already had their hearts and
Minds leaning or conforming to to the
world so is that what Hebrews 12 is
talking about or is this more isog jesis
of the biblical text meaning meaning is
it being read from the outside into the
text Hebrews 12:1 18-29 is the author
continuing his theme of the Lesser to
the greater I've talked about this
numerous times on this platform this
time he is comparing and contrasting
Mount Si over and against the Heavenly
Mount Zion for you have not come to what
may be touched a blazing fire and
darkness and Gloom and a tempest and the
sound of a trumpet and a voice whose
words made the hears beg that no further
messages be spoken to them for they
could not endure the order that was
given if even a Beast touches the
mountain it shall be stoned indeed so
terrifying was the sight that Moses said
I tremble with fear but you have come to
Mount Zion and to the city of the Living
God the heavenly Jerusalem and to
innumerable angels in fesal gathering
and to the assembly of the firstborn who
are enrolled in heaven and to God the
judge of all and to the spirits of the
righteous made perfect and to Jesus the
mediator of a New Covenant and to the
sprinkled blood that speaks a better
word than the blood of Abel and thus the
reading of God's holy word so he starts
by explaining how the New Covenant
believer has a better Mountain that they
can actually approach and without fear
if you recall in Exodus 19 which is what
he's referring to God presented himself
to the Israelites by means of descending
in a cloud that shrouded and covered the
entire mountain and like the author of
Hebrews notes anything or anyone that
touched this mountain would experience
death the scene was so terrifying that
the people sought to have a mediator
between them and God a role in which
Moses filled by the time time we get to
chapter 12 the author has already
explained back in chapters 3 and 4 how
Moses was a picture of Jesus Christ the
better mediator and his point here is
unlike Israel of old we can actually
approach god with boldness that Chasm
that existed between God and man at SI
has been alleviated through the person
and work of Jesus the better mediator of
a better Covenant sprinkled with better
blood and he says this as encouragement
like he has been giving all throughout
the book encouragement to approach the
throne of God not with fear but with
boldness
and it's after laying this out that we
get to the verse that Mark Cherry Picked
to try and read into the text the SDA
church and their doctrine of the shaking
see that you do not refuse him who is
speaking for if they did not Escape when
they refused him who warned them on
Earth much less will we escape if we
reject him who warns from Heaven at that
time his voice shook the Earth but now
he is Promised yet once more I will
shake not only the Earth but also the
heavens this phrase yet once more
indicates the removal of things that are
shaken that is things that have been
made in order that the things that
cannot be shaken May remain therefore
let us be grateful for receiving a
kingdom that cannot be shaken and thus
let us offer to God acceptable worship
with reverence and awe for our God is a
consuming fire and thus the reading of
God's holy word so the author is giving
an exhortation like he has throughout
the book a similar exhortation was made
back in Hebrews 4 for example to not
Harden our hearts to the gospel like
Israel did in the wilderness and failed
to enter into the promised land they had
the good news preached to them and
didn't believe here we see him say a
similar thing but this time with
reference to Israel at SI not in the
wilderness but the portion in focus is
versus 26- 28 the author clearly refers
to Exodus 19 regarding the shaking that
took place in the terror of God's
presence as well as Hagi 26
notice speaking about the coming of the
future Messiah Hagi says speak now to
zerubabel the son of shatil governor of
Judah and to Joshua the son of jehos the
high priest and to all the remnant of
the people and say who is left among you
who saw this house in its former glory
how do you see it now is it not as
nothing in your eyes yet now be strong o
zerubabel declares the Lord be strong oh
Joshua son of jehos the high priest be
strong all the people of the land
declares the Lord work for I Am with You
declares the Lord of hosts according to
the Covenant that I made with you when
you came out of Egypt my spirit remains
in your midst fear not for thus says the
Lord of hosts yet once more in a little
while I will shake the heavens and the
earth and the sea in the dry land and I
will shake All Nations so that the
treasures of all Nations shall come in
and I will fill this house with Glory
says the Lord of hosts the silver is
mine and the gold is mine declares the
Lord of hosts the latter Glory of this
house shall be greater than the former
says says the Lord of hosts and in this
place I will give peace declares the
Lord of hosts now I know we're doing a
lot of reading but please track with me
this is necessary to understand what
Hebrews 12 is actually saying notice
that there's even a lesser to the
greater mentioned in Hagi as well the
greater temple of God would come Jesus
Christ where the fullness of deity dwelt
bodily but in that haggi foretold that
when the Messiah comes there will be a
shaking in the heavens and the Earth
that drastically changes things there
will be a people brought in from all
tribes tongues peoples and Nations to
worship the true God not just National
Israelites which means the shaking in
Focus has to do with a radical change
what I often talk about with regards to
the new creation but that is what the
author is referring to in the verses
that Mark referenced the author is
citing Hagi and talking about how Jesus
came and shook all of heaven and earth
once more but this time it brought about
an unshakable Kingdom the Heavenly Mount
Zion a kingdom that cannot be thwarted
because Jesus is the king of kings and
Lord of lords who defeated Satan sin and
death and he will rule and Reign forever
and ever as all of his enemies are being
made a foot stol something the author
has already talked about numerous times
leading up to this chapter this passage
has nothing to do absolutely nothing to
do with the Seventh Day Adventist being
shaken out of the SDA church so that
what is unshakable in this case the SDA
church can remain while the fake SDA
converts are shakable and shaken out the
Seventh Adventist Church isn't the
unshakable kingdom of God folks Mark
simply engaged in word association
fallacy he sees the word shaking in
Hebrews 12 and then hitches the SDA
concept of the shaking to the paropy
which is supposed to prove it's biblical
this is a glorious portion of the
epistle which is documenting down how
Jesus's kingdom is superior to that of
any other because he came and redeemed
creation and now rules and Reigns over
it as king of kings establishing a
kingdom that will never end and cannot
be thwarted and we didn't look at it but
the same thing is said in Isaiah 11 that
no one will hurt or destroy God's
Mountain meaning it's unshakable this is
all being said in Hebrews as
encouragement to the original audience
who was tempted to return to the types
and shadows of the old Covenant we have
a better Mountain a better mediator
better blood and a better Kingdom than
simply National Israel did a kingdom
that was indeed shakable and had
imperfect Kings ruling over it now I
could go on and on but I do want to
close on another key observation that
really strikes at the heart of what I've
called the SDA Trifecta and that's the
character of Christ's Kingdom the good
news of the Gospel folks isn't simply
that Jesus can forgive you of your sins
this is absolutely true and it's part of
the good news but as Jesus himself
taught the gospel is the good news of
the Kingdom that's what Jesus went about
preaching that he was the foretold
Messiah that all of the law and the
prophets foretold of and those prophets
spoke of a day when the Messiah would
come and establish a kingdom that knows
no ends that flourishes in growth and
causes all of the Nations to stream up
to it but that isn't how the Seventh Day
Adventist Church describes the kingdom
of God we've listened before to numerous
Adventist leaders describe how in
Adventist theology the kingdom of God is
only a people not a territorial reign as
well as a Reign Over those people and
that Kingdom people is supposedly the
Seventh Day Adventist which makes sense
why mark would have used Hebrews 12 the
way that he did now there's a lot we
could look at regarding the kingdom of
God but I want to look at one aspect
from Jesus which really strikes a blow
to the whole debacle going on in the SDA
movement right now in Matthew 13 Jesus
says he put another Parable before them
saying the Kingdom of Heaven is like a
grain of mustard seed that a man took
and Seed in his field it is the smallest
of all seeds but when it has grown it is
larger than all of the garden plants and
becomes a tree so that the birds of the
air come and make nests in its branches
he told them another Parable the Kingdom
of Heaven is like leaven that a woman
took and hid in three measures of flower
till it was all leavened Jesus gave
multiple parables in this chapter about
the kingdom of God after the parable of
the wheat and the tears he says that the
kingdom of God can be thought about like
a small seed this small seed is planted
in a field but over time it gives
increase turning into something larger
than all of the other plants growing
into a fullon tree and this tree then
attracts Birds to it which come and make
nests within the tree in conjunction he
also uses leaven in a lump of dough as
another example just like dough that
starts with a rather small lump it
slowly and gradually Rises into
something much bigger and Fuller both of
these Parables parallel perfectly with
what Isaiah tells us about the kingdom
specifically in Isaiah 2 where he
foretold that the messiah's kingdom
would be established and the nations
would stream to it that's the birds
coming and making their nest in the tree
the same Isaiah that says in chapter n
that the kingdom of God would know no
ends and the increase of Christ
governance would continue
forever while Division and Schism are
brewing in the SDA Church leading to a
whittling down and downsizing the actual
kingdom of God is flourishing it's
expanding and growing people from all
tribes tongues peoples and nations are
hearing the gospel which is the means by
which the kingdom grows and they are
experiencing new life in Christ as
living stones in the great edifice that
is the Christian church with Christ as
the Chief Cornerstone and head of the
body the SDA Church isn't what it claims
based on simple analysis of the system's
own claims about itself using its own
standards divisions like this will only
continue to be a problem because 7th day
adventism was born out of a time-based
failed prophecy regarding the end of
time and the longer time goes on the
worse it gets for the movement and for
their very grandiose claims so just like
Mark was making an appeal to Adventist I
want to make one as well however he said
that his presentation was not for
Skeptics of adventism within their own
ranks and mine is if you're sick of all
the division and the confusion that
adventism has to offer and you feel like
you've been sold a bill of goods that
hasn't uh manifested what it promises
it's because you have and that's okay
many of us had to come to this hard
realization as well but there is a
better Mountain that you can come to and
we are on that mountain waiting for you
to join us if this is you feel free to
contact us at answering adventism tocom
where you will find resources and a way
to contact us don't forget to smash that
like button and subscribe and until next
time May Christ richly bless you in the
grace and peace won by him and his
vicarious death on the cross for Sinners
Hallelujah Mara until next
time
apostate did he say
that come on man
[Music]